[Music]
on this tuesday night roseanne archibald
on the record i am suspended because i
am speaking the truth the assembly of
first nations national chief alleging
misspent money there's lots in the afn
that's hidden and her claims of sexism
new accusations and resignations in
britain's government the crisis after
two key cabinet ministers quit the trail
of evidence left by the men accused in a
killing spree at this parade
we do believe cremo pre-planned this
attack for several weeks and new details
about the victims
plus powering forward hopefully it opens
the door to to give other opportunities
to other minorities the nhl's new
historic hire
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us the
assembly of first nations annual general
meeting is underway in vancouver the
session aims to set goals for the
upcoming year and reach resolutions on
critical issues but the official agenda
has been overtaken by infighting over
the future of its national chief
roseanne archibald nitu garcia is at the
meeting tonight anita you have some
breaking news
i do colleen after debating the
resolution afn membership have voted to
stop the temporary suspension of
national chief roseanne archibald this
comes after she was removed from the
agenda multiple times and added back on
at the last minute and was finally able
to address the assembly earlier today we
heard today that everybody wants to move
on from this issue and on to critical
issues on their agenda for later in the
week including indigenous child welfare
and climate change
i know kenny
hear a lot entangled in controversy the
elected national chief making an
unconventional entrance to the vancouver
convention center for the annual
meetings of the assembly of first
nations they erased me from the agenda
now they put me back on and so what i
want you to know is all of these actions
are because they want to silence
with supporters of all ages roseanne
archibald walking in and claiming the
crisis now gripping the organization
started when she rejected a million
dollar staff payout which she says
revealed bigger problems it's a real
misuse of funds that the afn has been
doing for years there have been millions
of dollars in payouts
at the afn and that's why we need this
forensic audit to show
all of these payouts and how they have
been misusing these funds after an
investigation into bullying and
harassment claims concluded last month
an archibald disclosed what the afn
executive has called confidential
information they suspended her with pay
and called the allegations of corruption
unfounded people are torn especially
the women chiefs
they are torn
with these events a fair
workplace investigation process
which the national chiefs words and
actions have made nearly impossible but
archibald's lawyer says whistleblower
policy is clear in the charter and the
afn committee never had the ability to
suspend her this suspension is unlawful
i do have a path out of this
we need to
establish
a new corporation based in our culture
and values
i only exist because all of you
put me in this position so an attack on
me is an attack on you
an alleged culture of backroom deals now
front and center as the assembly with
more than 400 in attendance is urged to
take back the week's meetings from the
afn executive
okay nitu what happens next
well colleen it was decided that first
thing on wednesday two other resolutions
will be voted on one of those is a
non-confidence motion motion which would
oust national chief the other is to
commence a forensic audit spanning the
last eight years of spending within the
afn as well as an internal investigation
into workplace toxicity
before they move on to any of the other
issues on their agenda for the rest of
the week it is said that those
resolutions will be voted on but colleen
there is such a deep divide within the
afn right now some calling this moment a
coup against the first woman national
chief of the afn while the executive is
saying that she disclosed confidential
information
and unlawfully so and that is why we're
at the place we are now colleen
interesting need to gotcha in vancouver
thanks nitu
britain's prime minister boris johnson
is clinging to his job tonight after two
of his most senior ministers resigned
from cabinet the health secretary and
chancellor or finance secretary say
they've lost confidence in johnson after
another embarrassing scandal played out
over the past few days our redmond
shannon joins us from london and redmond
bring us up to date on how these
resignations happened
well colleen it began with another
resignation last week the deputy chief
whip chris pincher of the ruling
conservative party stood down after he
was alleged to have groped two men at a
party then it emerged there were
previous misconduct allegations against
him it was alleged boris johnson knew
about them when he appointed pincher as
deputy whip at first the prime
minister's office said johnson was not
aware of the allegations then they said
he didn't know about specific
allegations
then they said he did know but forgot
this evening johnson went on tv to
apologize and to admit that he had been
told
but i'm giving you uh the absolute truth
as far as i can remember about what
happened
can people trust you of course they can
i'm telling you all this i'm telling you
exactly what happened and
uh i'm i'm
i'm coming out to uh to explain it
because i'm i'm i've fell out with
people if i may say so chris saying
things on my uh behalf or trying to save
people
trying to say things about what i knew
or didn't know and i'm trying to explain
to you uh exactly what happened as i
remember it and colleen just as that
interview was being aired two senior
ministers the health secretary and the
chancellor of the exchequer or the
finance minister here tweeted out their
resignation letters
saji javid and rishi sunak are both
believed to have aspirations for the top
job
redmond what happens next for boris
johnson
well colleen just last month johnson
survived a tory no confidence vote with
59 of his mps supporting him
that was in the wake of the revelations
about the gatherings that took place in
downing street and government offices
breaking pandemic lockdown rules johnson
and sunak both received police fines as
part of that
the conservative party rules say they
can't challenge boris johnson again for
a year but members can change those
rules
and with the tories lagging behind in
the polls many of johnson's mps may
think the only way they can keep their
jobs at the next election is if the
prime minister is removed colleen redman
shannon in london thanks redmond
officials in illinois say a seventh
person has now died after the attack on
a july fourth parade near chicago as
disturbing new details emerged tonight
the suspect robert e creamo iii has been
charged with seven counts of
first-degree murder police say he
planned the massacre for weeks and
dressed in women's clothing so he could
blend with the crowd during his escape
as jackson prescott reports before the
attack the accused gunman amassed a
small arsenal of weapons all legally
obtained
the horror that unfolded on the fourth
of july was meticulously planned weeks
in advance
police say the gunman shot a
high-powered rifle at random into the
crowd from a rooftop overlooking the
parade route after firing more than 70
shots investigators say he tried to
blend into the panicked crowd during the
attack primo was dressed in woman's
clothing and investigators do believe he
did this to conceal his facial tattoos
and his identity and help him during the
escape at street level witnesses
describe terror after surviving the
massacre several doctors watching the
parade rush to help the victims you saw
massive amounts of blood in the people
that were gone their injuries were
horrific i've had dust on the table i've
had you know i've seen i've seen death
and at least i can understand that i
know
why it happened
but here i can't understand just the
senseless taking of a life the dead and
wounded range from ages 8 to 85.
victims like nicholas toledo a
grandfather visiting family and jackie
sondheim who worked at a local synagogue
the suspect 21-year-old robert cremo the
third was arrested by police late monday
investigators still don't have a motive
but they're focusing on the suspect's
online posts including dozens of violent
images and cartoons that showed an
interest in mass murder we need to have
a very real national conversation about
why we're okay with allowing weapons of
war on our streets like so many of
america's recent mass killings this one
involved guns that were legally
purchased a nation that's inundated with
as many as 400 million personally owned
firearms i think we can safely say this
will continue to happen until something
different
occurs it's pretty dramatic and like so
many american communities the town of
highland park is now forever changed by
a senseless act that claimed innocent
lives
jackson proskow global news washington
russian forces are stepping up attacks
on ukraine's two eastern provinces
in the aftermath of ukraine's strategic
pull out from licit chance russia is now
focusing on driving ukrainian forces out
of the eastern lehansk and donetsk
regions
heavy russian artillery and rocket
strikes are hitting not only the
remaining military targets in the region
but also homes and civilian facilities
like this school in harkief ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky says russia
is trying to drive ukrainian soldiers
off the battlefield by forcing them to
protect civilians
finland and sweden have taken another
major step in the process of joining the
nato alliance today the 30 nato allies
signed an assession protocol for the two
nordic countries that process will go
into effect once the swedish and finnish
parliaments ratify the decision and is
expected to take up to a year
finland and sweden's accession to nato
will mark one of the biggest shifts in
european security in decades and further
increase russia's isolation in the wake
of its invasion of ukraine
dubious distinctions for a couple of
canadian airlines coming up where they
rank on reliability
if you aren't flying off on summer
vacation consider yourself lucky right
now many canadian airports are a tangled
mess of long lines cancelled flights and
lost luggage after a long pandemic pause
the airline industry is struggling to
keep up with demand and as ross lord
tells us when it comes to performance
canada's two largest carriers have
fallen way behind their american
counterparts
pandemic restrictions have been relaxed
but airline passengers are more tense
than ever flights are routinely delayed
or canceled our flight today is delayed
an hour so far i flew from denver on air
canada here with a connecting flight to
lisbon air canada decided at the last
and while we were mid-air
that they were going to give our seats
away
bump us i got delayed three times then
they cancelled it i'm kind of surprised
the way it just kind of kept rolling for
no explanation as to why on top of
widespread delays and luggage chaos
there's troubling new evidence about how
unreliable canada's two main carriers
have become it's based on monthly
information gathered by the analytics
company cerium cerium's on-time
performance metrics for the 30-day
period ending july 3 show american
carriers delta and alaska airlines top
the list at more than 80 percent
reliable at the bottom of the list air
canada flights arriving as scheduled
just 38 of the time the worst of 10
large north american carriers westjet
was not much better arriving on time
only 54 percent of the time some
analysts say there's been a lack of
strategic planning
governments
departments and the airports and the
airlines were flying ironically by the
seat of their pants in an industry that
requires tremendous coordination always
has
the advocacy group air passenger rights
says it's being swamped with complaints
placing the blame squarely on the
airlines
so now instead of
overselling individual flights
they are overstaying the network
capacity by scheduling more flights
than than
than the facilities the infrastructure
can handle
in an email statement air canada says
it's working with all of its partners to
improve the industry's performance the
westjet statement says the airline has
stabilized its operations but apologizes
for the industry collectively falling
short plenty of work to do before air
travel in canada truly takes flight
again
ross lord global news
contending with a lengthy heat wave and
subsequent drought italy has declared a
state of emergency it will give the
government extra funding and power to
respond to scorching conditions and
water shortages threatening the country
the focus will be on easing droughts in
the country's north including the po
river valley an area suffering its worst
drought in 70 years and which accounts
for roughly a third of the country's
agriculture production
soaring temperatures were blamed for
triggering a glacial landslide in the
italian alps on sunday five people
remain missing after 48 hours all
identified as italian climbers who were
caught on the mountain during the
avalanche so far seven people have been
confirmed dead another eight injured a
copy of one of the world's most famous
paintings has been targeted by climate
protesters
our future is
from the group just stop oil glued
themselves to a copy of leonardo da
vinci's the last supper and spray
painted the phrase no new oil below the
artwork shutting down a section of the
royal academy of arts in london in the
group's latest demonstration against the
use of fossil fuels
while in connor homes i tried to commit
suicide three times
i had what a teenager says he endured in
a group home and how he's thriving now
you're watching global national
[Music]
while some consider their teenage years
among the best in their life for liam
smith they were the darkest at 15 he was
placed in ontario's child welfare system
an experience so traumatizing he tried
to take his own life for much of that
time he lived at a group home operated
by a company called connor homes a
private for-profit company that global
news in partnership with aptn has been
investigating for months what it's like
inside the homes and how those kids are
treated is often shrouded in secrecy but
tonight we get liam's story first hand
carolyn jarvis reports
liam smith was only 13 when his mom died
in a car accident
smiles faded from photos and grief
turned to agony when he says his family
turned on him
the two different family members i was
with couldn't
didn't want to take care of me
and so he eventually arrived on the
doorstep of a group home run by connor
holmes a place his life would unravel
even further everything was like scored
out of one did you make your bed did you
shower like when i'm depressed i'm not
showering and when you're sick from
school and you don't want to get up to
eat there goes half your points when
kids didn't score high enough freedoms
were clawed back
and a rare chance for liam to see his
half-brother was taken away we're going
to go to the peterborough zoo got
canceled for having a bad mental health
week for liam finding a sense of family
inside those walls was nearly impossible
especially when he says the workers who
were supposed to care for him would quit
in a matter of days or weeks we would
bet like snacks and stuff over how long
people would last because they left that
frequently yeah like every three months
there would be almost like a whole new
team according to former workers many
staff were untrained to help kids with
complex needs which meant when liam had
a tough day some didn't have the skills
to help him
and too frequently he says he'd end up
being physically restrained they would
like hold your your wrists
like
like this um like you're on the ground
and then somebody would hold your legs
connor holmes which declined an
on-camera interview said group home
staff receive regular training and every
child receives wrap-around supports from
a multi-disciplinary team including
therapists
still for liam that wasn't enough
while in conor holmes i tried to commit
suicide three times
his mental health which he says was fine
before his mom passed began to plummet
it felt like you weren't worth anything
there was just nothing nothing ever to
do you're so bored it's like i don't
even want to wait these three years so
i'm out of care
like i'd rather just go now
after nearly two years at connor holmes
liam moved to a group home run by a
different company where he stayed until
he was 18.
today he is a success story he lives
independently and has a job
but that success was built mostly alone
and in the memory of what love once felt
like it takes a village to raise a child
but i don't think there was a village
there for us
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
game changer next the new nhl gm making
history twice
haley wickenheiser has a new role with
the toronto maple leafs assistant
general manager the hockey hall of famer
and four-time olympic gold medalist has
been working in player development for
the leaf since 2018. she'll continue in
that department as assistant gm the
fourth woman to be promoted to that role
in the nhl
the san jose sharks have broken one of
the few remaining color barriers in
professional sports naming mike greer as
the first black general manager in nhl
history while greer's hiring is being
hailed as an historic first as mike
delay reports it comes decades after
black athletes in other leagues rose to
the front office
hi sharks fans it's mike i'm your new gm
and with that history has been made and
yes mike greer says he's proud to be
named the first black gm in nhl history
but he says it's what he does with it
that will define his cultural impact my
job is to do the best i can for the san
jose sharks organization and if i do
that hopefully it opens the door to to
give other opportunities to other
minorities to to get in front office
positions and and maybe lead a team down
the road as well it's a road he hopes
has fewer bumps than the ones paved by
men like william the first black man to
play in the nhl and herb carnegie who
had a tryout in the nhl a decade before
ori but was denied the opportunity to
play this week it was announced carnegie
would be inducted into the hall of fame
as a builder for a life spent trying to
make sport more inclusive it turned out
that he was the one black man that was
always the first in in
different aspects of his life to do
things
and so he has a long list of he was the
first
um and you would think that when you you
know here we are
80 years 100 years later and we're still
saying
that we have to say this is the first
every sport has had its pioneers wayne
embry became the first black gm in the
nba in 1972 bob watson followed in
baseball in 1993 ozzie newsome in the
nfl in 2002 and now in 2022 mike greer
in the nhl and this is actually greer's
second first he was the first
african-american player born and trained
in the u.s to make the nhl eastwood
shoots it and deflected
women's hockey is also embracing
progress the toronto six franchise was
recently purchased by a minority group
of partners that includes bernice
carnegie we are the first
owners
of the
professional hockey team for women
barriers are being broken down sport and
society in general are better for it
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is the north
settlement at the lanzo meadows historic
site in hay cove newfoundland and
labrador we love seeing your canada
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here tomorrow good night
[Music]
you